wax into the shampoo there are
simplifying being the puppet car park at
the side of the Civic sweet please do
not delay out your evacuation to collect
any belongings please do not return to
the building until given permission to
do so by the council staff and please
note that this leads it will be all you
have recorded would you please be
upstanding to receive a chairman has a
hidden link end up chatting evening
everybody welcome to our meeting firstly
I'd like to do you ask I'll start again
keeping everybody and they were so
private as well on their computers which
is right the first item on the agenda is
for my checking and the Reverend
adulthood to help us in practice cottage
but i'll be giving another story it was
a very religious couple and they were
tearing the Holy Land during the
Christmas season and you started to be
very painful for them to spend Christmas
Eve in Bethlehem which is where Jesus on
a right and there they searched high
life for a room but numbers available
any price finally they pulled up in
front of the hilton in Bethlehem and the
husband got out of the car telling his
wife say there sweetie let me see if I
can do something for us you approach the
desk and the receptionist told him there
were no rooms sorry so it's Christmas
Eve how busiest time no matter how much
the man offered to pay the receptionist
said he has nothing for them finding the
man told the reception I bet if I told
you my name was chosen that the woman
waiting in the car was called Mary and
that she had an uber
infant you find us a room oh well some
of the receptionist I suppose I worse
okay so the man i can guarantee they're
not coming tonight to give us a room
shall we pray let us pray giving thanks
for the beauty of this world that we
have inherited we give thanks and the
reminder of the recent worldwide paris
conference of our responsibility as
stewards to look after god's creation
and all its resorts it's for ourselves
and future generations for our diversity
of race culture religion and politics we
give thanks and now desire to work
together in harmony and in peace for
those called to serve in local
communities and politics we keep things
as they seek to act on behalf of the
electorate hoping is also the experience
better lives for this counts slightly
give thanks to debate and discuss in
freedom and liberty and accountability
and to assert our democratic rights and
for a world that seems at times
extremely difficult to living we give
thanks for the challenges and
opportunities that it throws up and for
the part that we complain it and for
those who know the words and wish to
join me with me in saying that we're
going to sing the Lord's Prayer our
Father which art in heaven hallowed be
thy name thy kingdom come Thy will be
done on earth as
and give us this day our daily bread and
forgive us our trespasses as we can just
against us and lead us not into
temptation but deliver us from evil for
thine is the kingdom forever and ever
and now as many among us will celebrate
the birth of Jesus Christ this Christmas
time may the joy of the Angels the
wonder of the Shepherd's the
perseverance of the wise men and the
peace of the Christ child fill our
hearts this Christmas time and the
blessing of God Almighty the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit remain with us
now and always army and they I wish you
personally a pleasant evening together
and a happy Christmas goodbye thank you
very much and it's thank you we hope you
have a thing for one for the center as
well
only one
its jaws
change today is apologies for that
absence thank you cheering me up
counselor hazelwood apologies in the
office Thank You counselors no Spencer
and counselor july no Kevin it's catch
like algae a heightened this Jeep is
active on Monday with 1755
to disadvantage of the beauty of the
20th terrible stronger german term on
the premise and testament to the last
meeting as a look quite correct as the
under is from the last meeting I have
actually excited I not received a bit
responsible counselor walls the book
value on banging your leader all the
questions have been raised and the chief
executive States Britain appear i see a
maximum five times and i have an hour
since receive a responsive writing to my
lights and chairman did you come up into
five or six but not receive a
responsible young latin for chairman
there still business pakistani food
meeting before the last meeting Thank
You German lousy knows you okay
therefore maybe that pop up the best of
it are you happy with me to sign it that
make things going to Kramer very very
much st item 38 declarations of interest
capsule also a blissful so you can that
must be
it's very anybody dissipation for
interest nobody helped me go over
arching food and its announcement too
much air I have event this week a
gentleman that's come from the videos
exactly the Bible I know 20 years ago
also pleased to accept one vote Lisa
number one for me today because I shall
be given it to one of my great
grandchildren we make the next component
so I'd like to go forward and so thank
you may I present you this Bible we've
inscribed it in the preface it's a very
important book to wear to Christians
throughout the world and I commend it to
you especially the New Testament but
also if I may I would like to present
with this [ __ ] jelly bean and the
reason why I want just entering this
jelly babies is the word has been used
twice this evening at Christmas time we
use this word peace we use it a lot of
Christmas and it doesn't mean the
absence of war the Bible means it to be
completeness and wholeness what the
cherry baby for those that don't know
was launched in 1919 and it was launched
under the name of peace babies and they
sold them up until the Second World War
and then because of rationing etcetera
they cease production but they
relaunched them in 1954 as jelly babies
yeah so I can present them and I what
they think the word peace there if you
look at a jelly baby it is able to take
quite a bit of pressure but once the
pressure is released it it can return to
its normal form now the council the
whole members of the council you and you
have immense importance to our community
but we the community generally don't
take care don't appreciate you enough we
put you under lots of pressure and we
expect you to be able to just bounce
back and that is no easy no easy feat
but if i make amend the words in that
book it tells you how to achieve that
how to take the pressure wing and how to
be able to return to normal and live a
sane and sensible life and the work
piece is in
is completeness and wholeness so please
enjoy the journey baby and yourself
don't get to the Grand order and thank
you very much indeed sir let me go you
let's go although one or two people well
I will only sit down there and I always
have sweets that are passed around and
on some occasions I actually don't bring
Jenny baby but then my teeth and I was
alone there the other side they don't
get them for be but we probably look
really all of this but after all these
years the woman took pains in the First
World War and these candles the seedling
now they're back they are you thank you
so very much but very peaceful Christmas
I said yes this is Campbell thank you
Jim and one day even cook at least so
I'm going to make me melt if I night and
I just like to work man you can suck out
and softly to this chamber and I hope
you has a long happy six months in this
I do hope you enjoy teaching Martin
chairman mao make a full proposal that
the bag of jelly babies commences at
this age is Christmas and do I have a
second I thought I honest people I'm a
sick here and I won't even give them to
my deck with me I would kind of sitting
public special scoffs a lot but what I'm
looking fit is more than an hour third
media and when you sleep the chamber
tonight each one you could have one
official title
the 7th army council is the business
owner from cancer couple are to write
about the count for something to the
council council a couple of shimmer
along cessful six months but by working
cows with the counselor softly I
remember in May nineteen eighty-four
somebody pushing needs hope you i
enjoyed by four years of accounts i hope
you have got to say Chris yes it
happened a long time but I'm not far
behind you and also nobody have a
precipice love you and hope you find it
very impressive and that you'll find it
and we could try to do things but it
takes a majority mobile whatever we do
which we can be the door for mission of
thank you very much now I'm standing
Saints finding out because I want to be
the announcer for the chair in the first
instance i'd like to say for everybody
how much I've enjoyed going out the
breakfast in to me everybody add the
street right across Southeast of England
from far away scribal was worth it
account around London and parcel ethics
look at where I've gone everybody's army
this way to come from and I've been very
pleased to say but do you know something
airport yes and do your mother wanna see
island when we got others paper yes so I
think term and say well first of all
and watch your district I'm very proud
to be able to let people realize just
how much we have to offer in our
particular area and I'm very powerful
also I'll have invited the schools to
churches and all sorts of groups big
roots if it broke and everything else
right the way round and i have found
everybody very pleased so listen and and
will be involved with them that i would
like to be a very special thank you
tonight and based some of you don't
think i'm very funny and I'm not being
funny I would very much like to pack
Bailey town council at the last minute
when the peace decided they couldn't do
anything on the roads and you came
forward and you found people to suffer
to stand guard so that the market rates
are very high street and all the things
to do with the of the service and movie
commemorative it Fonzie for many and the
principal were there and for everyone to
enjoy and I would very much and see if I
just like the town councils for doing
that at the last minute a saver day it
may be absolutely wonderful and at the
same time the other areas abroad trip
from fouling this one across the camera
everywhere have their own services and
each one of them was well attended and
was a lot of thought and now that mean
up day and thank you very much for that
look at that I also say I'm very proud
that the Christians coming we all hear
some light and going to have a hopeful
children even without mercy
also we become so she say that there's a
multiple a nice question good question
hey Jen with your permission I'll begin
there are people sitting counseling my
first question of are you chair the
support area or thing bar and what are
the other things are going to practice q
just sorry you change around the in
order that's a future I'm glad you're
staying again sorry about that so take
it now it's family project as you're
working to begin funny I did them in one
or the Chairman I pork chops with a
chain around them yes cut the portfolio
Hogan for me what happens to 470
saplings the printer parts in Cherry
Orchard Park commemorate the hundredth
anniversary of the start World War one
this is a joint collaboration between
the Western Front Association the
women's trust and lots of District
Council commemorate a 470 men of this
district could be diet during a conflict
and get emancipated it's in the person
show that's customer person
thank you and in answer to question one
eric has often sell your exact needs
have been deliberately cut by an unknown
individual or individuals we are waiting
to see how many will produce new shoots
in the spring that are suitable to
promote as a replacement we did not wish
to draw attention to this deliberate act
of vandalism in the hope that the trees
are the better shots of reestablishment
out of the line line Thank You chairman
Thank you Thank You chairman that's
slightly dif of the actual response we
got on the lifework we'll have lots of
website which just turn I said it was
total vandalism now those 470 saplings
complete with states as well chairman
equality they've done in representation
of western front of 1915 to porn Avenue
remembrance their chairman of the
thought that this association especially
taking into account it's where our
heritage would do better than actually
not even informed the war councils a
citizen habit i would also thought
chairman that they would have informed
the police of this random or so-called
very matter vandalism and all of the
lights were thought that the prime
number would have been a title the place
for that massive chairman it seems that
heaven and earth and moved from cut down
christmas tree but 470 on don't go down
so chairman I'd like to know when these
trees will be replanted because i
actually think is that it was a and acts
upon gross incompetency chairman and
nervous on the ground maintenance people
not to run the tracks up over the area
thank you can't do this is my cousin
thank you and i got quite lots where the
vegetables on there
office is full of taking notes I will
discuss it while focuses we will provide
division responsive counselor Gordon and
the rest of the Dead counselors they hmm
thank you 30 chair number two then right
are you Chinese also our question of the
portfolio of the environment helps is
restructure construct a second berm
adjacent to the original one which is
constructed in the wrong place which was
the pet memorial wall should have been
placed in the corner which now second
one has been built there but the
original one was put in the middle of
the field they were going straight to
construct a second one to face it to
make it like an above-ground trencherman
chips tortilla reviews and it was also
to access the entrance the area
remembers the trees there were
sufficient money in the budget to be
downtown that seems to fallen by the
wayside I like to know good wife Lady
chairman Tom I selected and the concerns
raised we got no faintest attained of
such a design and also regarded the
logistics of school children visiting
aside with such limited facilities
taking these concerns into account it is
believed that the best course of action
was not received this project thank
general Thank You gentleman yes the
previous tape of that department and
agreed that the works would be done and
that the only thing he was holding this
up the time was the lack of the chaos of
structural engineer who was involved on
the flood prevention matters and after
that was done he would be correct and as
it's a graph above browse it would not
cause problems for the local children
also schools being formed there were no
facilities the toilets or anything else
there and it's like a standard trip that
they do to cherry orchard farm and
Cherry Orchard Park anyway so its
chairman and refrain I don't take that
it's a question or is actively comment
nice a common show thank you very much
and then it's a question please item
three gentlemen thank you I you know
this one sorry caps off to for ice and
three is the other one come through too
many now happens when that check my
lovable person support failure helps our
planning as the applicant the
application North London Road withdrawn
their appeal if not have they given an
undertaking but they will do so
otherwise was not forced funding
problems the reckon brag about the
oriflamme found rival junction okay
thank you munching as a short answer to
question one no and as a short answer to
question two yes but in for some people
understand that the appeal has not been
formally withdrawn as yet but the
applicant has indicated this will happen
following you she'll the planning
consent in the meantime the appeal is
being held in abeyance by the planning
inspectorate thank you very thank you
that's the same us to have last on share
my backyard became written undertaking
from the applicant chairman because it's
them saying yes we will do it afraid
doesn't have much choice you're talking
about in the region five and a half
million pounds and that's a lot of money
so there's a chain livelihoods of the
portfolio holder insists on some
offering confirmations connected
and your hairy magic question i will ask
that a question chairman if he will do
that okay it's like a cheering any
further information will be given back
as soon as we have it thank you very
very much I can now you pay the bills no
little German right now I'm German are
you to the council ppl park environment
customer virgin stated to this council
the hives village shuttle takes
approximately 70,000 pounds per annum
have you really go shaded the culture as
I'm sure then was remember my book my
blessing the portfolio holder essex
county council when a stated figures the
correct figures 187,000 pounds against
contribution from then of 33,000 300
pounds you state the shortboard may not
be savings to the grounds latest project
can you confirm the figures your pasta
70,000 pounds against my 1 187 thousand
pounds and that there is no short for
the Browns masons contract saying is
can't cut which would include favre
unconcerned 150 2,700 pounds of
chocolate version hm enough shall talk a
little bit faster new translations
contract was lured into Center 2013 the
concourse abated from the prices within
the build quality and discussion
contractor to reflect the estimator
posture center towers and out previous
postings were based on experiment yet we
do sleep just a bit slow yes of course
you could from 5.com opinion of college
a mannequin reviews hospitals were based
upon the interim contacts contracts of
signal represent such a very for money
due to the temporary nature I've ever
economy of scale of the cheese for a
larger contract Thank You chairman thank
you
you gotta find a question I have
something with exact measurements I
could please Jeremy connection Joe yes I
don't listen please the check the
question is chairman the court got a
half the environment I negotiated
contracts I know the savings were
outlined Oh for cosplay so therefore
chairman my question still remains is
there sufficient in the grounds makers
contract saying is to cover what I feel
and must be notified and actually
confirmed biases County Council as a
hundred fifty fifty two thousand seven
hundred pounds your phone Thank You
chairman i was guessing officer the
formularies response which has the
borden and it also be sent to all
councillors thank general much thank you
no joke will get close with German Bayou
question to put on your phone your phone
or failure of the garmin you please
inform me in this authority how much is
still in the pot the grounds maintenance
contracts ladies hey chairman as
explained to cancel order last month the
additional brass cutting of your
membership is such as I by dr. District
Council we have the choice to do the
best we can for the 35,000 received from
ethics and no other cutting the grass
surgery or we have a choice to provide a
better service choir residence pull back
para construir Council the successful
awarded the successful awarding of
around basement contract in december two
thousand and thirty-two live it
approximately two
fifty thousand pounds worth of annual
savings these long posts are factored
into the subsequent financial planning
select cycles to reflect a lower and
your expenditure on open spaces
management these savings contribute
towards further funding cuts this is
very so hot for funding anyways juice
sailings our feelings the budget process
this cast recording will be aware they
generally I'm supplemental at my
chairman thank you yeah it's a yes yes
or so 450,000 pounds negotiated 400,000
pounds placement studies I've lights
were asked the portfolio hostile
environment in the last council meeting
chef she stays at the grounds verge
extras came out of the sayings from the
grounds maintenance contract my question
was can you please inform me in this
authority how much is still in the pot
to the grounds maintenance savings she
got away around the question chairman
lastly thank you very much thank
chairman i will discuss with offices we
provide written response to the council
evolved in a live setting later talk out
there's a plate chiller very much do I
ask there's nothing it's not one general
direction I think for this no I wish to
report our destiny oh how are you
chairman another question to pop out of
focus knowledge from yo hold up the
armors Oh Kevin portfolio holder for me
authority 150 thousand pounds of soup I
or investments agree to the last council
came from or sure to sit down way from
other responsive writing counselors fact
illusion German expenditure on please
face and
open spaces as part of the capital
program outline to the medium term
financial plan as agreed at full council
on the term configurator ship thank you
thank you thank you so that's probably a
written response to that one oops I lost
your budget cuts cut last year and I've
not in this he is idea our next question
gems it's also good for failure
operative our own kind of put failure
horrible for me one works pencil player
in Cherry Orchard not being completed
personally laser needs to stop dog down
in fire area because of children to get
a hang-up inspiration there was a budget
son for this and size was meant to be
was due to be completed after my
election sorry for for signal thanks
Jamie and there is to be no full war
dream of the expenditure of capital
funds that for any fencing around the
player actuarial Japan may I that when i
received councillor bottoms question
this is first time i'd heard of this
this addicting however is something i am
happy to see football consideration it's
a project to the new financial year its
chairman thank you very much chairman I
good news rings I will throw in the
questions of portfolio holder finance
until the next meeting as i'm going to
give you much chance to answer the
questions man it saves on to the word
for it responses to our questions are
you very much and that will come up in
the next is so this is better Thank You
chairman roaster so I Council Orton's
got the horse a question and careful
doctor woman asked in the portfolio
holder in for me how much it has taught
us to have
structural engineer work from the first
alleviation skis and hell for this form
part of rocks district councils and
Lincoln Essex County Council the answer
is the approximate what's in style time
will be 3500 pounds of the year this
does not form part of our DC's much
ranging from Essex County Council
however it should be pointed out the
menu of the scheme of benefit to cite in
our ownership and responsibility hmm
thank you very much thank you very much
and with that we will now go on for item
6 is that my own business on that item
sir even then for go on to item 7 and
that is for note that's important
meeting I know German sorry there is
something from the business from last
council I've stated earlier chairman
when I protested the minute German there
was items that are still valid one of
the other site is the response the
response from chief executive Andrea's
question and the other i fking chairman
is actually receive written response for
council awards question for my questions
council war unfortunate that was sadly
incorrect have some waters responsible
feels incorrect to say from the minutes
of details whereas the SEC tember report
chennai and create an inter man and say
that and would you mind I'm glad to help
you sent an answer because I baby put it
in the wrong content no I don't think
such ever will I'm other factors Chapman
it's just in terms of your you agenda
business from this council meeting
refers to outstanding business from
general items not the previous meetings
thank you my comeback place because I
don't know where F actually go through
this particular item these [ __ ] from
the last council meeting ok so I'm sorry
such a stance but very briefly yep they
obviously showman see response I got
from the poor fellow helper planning was
that it was a sep tember vultureman
unfortunately Congress on tax appeal
that January about refusal rod and set
their approval secondly i'd love to see
a good responsible guards and still
funding and thirdly i received a
response yesterday have fought the end
to my question to counsel the person
which i think is against the council
procedures because every membership save
a copy of it which is why i sent it out
last night and on that chairman it
states that there was not complaints at
all for the last set of burnings
admission is Farley at all this a
fortune shown those incorrect can I am
but in their cafe that as this came out
as an answer yesterday it's really too
soon but everybody's have understood it
and looked at it so up from the chair
and this will go back and come back next
month if you aren't showing us quite a
pretty much so the fact of 63 64 are 32
which is now there's no be able to make
it for large Modest Proposal from it and
then we now go on try some sense which
as I said before is your notes of all
the many things have taken place doing
this term are you happy with
and then item 8 and this is a very big
folder which everybody should have a
Romeo yes everybody should have a crappy
thing and are my perfect and I will take
questions on this evening but if you
want to ask questions on this you must
give then down the page them out of what
you're talking about just have something
powerful and I've got to say that on
this one it's under item 8 and it's a
stroke one and the first item on this
even revised contract procedurals your
question of come along in a moment I'm a
cancer that so the first one from the
vapir it revised contract procedure
rules is it result and are you happy
with that report that comes under 1.3
everybody happy with that matter of time
so please okay thank you very much and
now number two statements and licensing
quality and it's very points on that and
they on that one it resolved under 2.3
to resolve this one again it's in the
book and I all happy with that
resolution result through an hour to
handle 'is thank you very much and then
number three is a statement of the
licensing policy game the Gaming Act and
other the page on our own 8.2
point for is a lot more photos result on
that one are you happy with that please
breathe breathe thank you very much and
then number four it's a bpa Treasury a
smug reduce okay are you happy with that
page result in an hour shower can you
send it up a little reading number five
it's a quarter to at the 2015-16
financial management before how's that
going to come true uncle some questions
and some observations way and Kieran
just can I just say could you give us a
pages but you're talking about in this
so members know what the time with my
best I'm for the same items in it is
extremely hard to follow 244 post
docking I'm sitting bats and balls on
shortness some brought supper here to my
best but i'll begin with on page eight
point 201
and we bought them looking at I was
hoping maybe next summer some others
exploded out is that five you know it's
under one internalize the earth it's
five different items here no reason was
officially suck at the Battle the
awesome them Christ interpret basically
and start the expenditure and thurs so
it's pretty though isn't a tuple 201 is
expected to be about over 500,000 pounds
less on the aluminum budget but it's
significant I the fondant is the first
question it's 500,000 to blow up of the
vehicle issue what's hard for bigger
last year how much slower we don't know
about I might add the opposite the
cottages thank you can survive and
things pointed to thank you question and
in terms of the overall understand that
I'm here to chew on staffing yet well
under spin trigger is closer to seven
hundred thousand doctor 500,000 and that
is in comparison to an undefended
580,000 in the last financial year you
asked also for confirmation in terms of
the overall budget figure that we had
for 1415 in budget for 1415 was 7.1
million and the original budget for 1516
was 6.4 million and I just sort of add
to that and provide a little bit of
clarity in terms of how the other
offenders been generated stay sitting
fleet riveted to the senior management
team restructured which we will see the
full year effect within this financial
year and 200,000 if that one to spend
was how did it come for when we
certainly medium-term resource strategy
I'm clever thank you um certainly as a
way of trying to draw how about what we
spread an officer
what we spend on for what we call your
car park I can't raise a couple of years
back but our total income from car or
net income from car parking the street
how you through the syllabus of our
eighth highest paid employees so nobly
to be happy if we hadn't got was a typo
employees we won't have to try to copper
advice is this new approach but
nonetheless it was correct and I
wondered with the organization how many
seek them what's the cause funny thing a
level designer I think either also in
terms of the the net pancakes car park
income for 2015-16 figure that we happen
in our counselor is a 276,000 which is a
poor can spend the actual top eight eyes
page and employees salaries total
524,000 representing sixty percent and
they're all in comparison to 14 15 which
i think is your original question the
overall percentage was seventy two
percent of the overall net car parking
which was eight hundred forty-four
thousand at the time thank you i think
i've completed before so what Nick was a
boy how we going to be structured I
think you can get worse as well before
we were all that car parking tub was
covering employees Wow situation is
slightly more balanced now but it's good
looking at my next question I'm so much
find it you probably have a person and
apology for the awesome I think I'm
saying on the there wasn't all things
window
somebody check characters sorry I had no
dis counselor they force you apply sorry
to you and snow before can't cancel
black moves on I just would like to say
for the record that there is no direct
correlation between car parking charges
and thin from leasing offices I just
found a political point coming on and I
just opted for opiate to mention it
thank you very much thank you I did
mighty moe's not for one second what yes
like on the window can't find something
hey watch it once the tube is thing
about this one was thank you you see
what a fun doesn't possess about the
window is exactly on budget true we did
anything else is like a bubble be like I
wonder what was happening here
so in terms of the agile movement above
it out for the firm expects the details
from our accounts i see understanding of
it betta particular why we had a a
positive [ __ ] and in the year today
position which is what's driving the
information that the budget the stated
is 16.7 primarily aligned to a
depreciation we charge at the end of the
financial year that makes up a
substantial element of the budget and
it'll be know exactly what that's likely
to be that's why I sort of report your
mind so it's expected to be balanced but
the reason it shows a surface the mems
for depreciation is you're not yet being
charged to the account okay probably is
ok maybe sometimes we can discuss how do
you measure depreciation on a symphony
or window I'm rightful for me let us
come back around it mainly associate
don't quite understand how do you go
down a question I have a lot of painted
over but that's the prime of your name
again I have got some observations that
luncheon and because this is you are
speaking to report you can keep them
very pretty please but we're in
altamonte to thank you because there's a
saying amongst believe the ruthless is
cynical but you can't make an omelet
without breaking eggs I think it's
simpler than that if you can't do
anything coming with the A's and as a
council makes of ourself we've given
stuff too
right now I've seen the party much the
problems in planning enforcement too
obvious and ever babe and I've seen the
problems in planning which led to us
having to pay costs or at least the pit
with Richie 1 i'd sing in a multi-panel
the probabilities of the month I've seen
the calls have come up with if you
mentioned using few committee about 30
sessions we're now linked for some
reasons may be completing incidental but
we now look as many zero-rated food
establishment imposing as salvetti comes
a point at buzz we put together and it's
my concern that way up near the top back
of stuff so much an elderly shortly
things are going to let the bugs not to
the extent but there's a vast
complacency lounge about this and we
need to look at that I mean certainly
have teeth soft members where they need
thank you don't you thank you very much
and can your comments anybody else so
therefore 5.2
resolution I thank you very much to the
people and then we go I'm sorry for caps
agenda jargon see 534 of each other with
Lucien probably the civilizations
whatever you have you are not coming on
to them Vicki 5.2 15.2 two three four
and five so are you in agreement with
all those five resolutions please my
kind of show of hands let anybody again
thank you very much now we go up to six
have to local can let the Medical
Council tech support from scheme I am
this mother very back this is already
canceled mr. money thank you chillin I
refer the patient if you could be my
moment the hunter and move up in the
line for sale oh ok I think it's based
on number 43 okay come out the whole
team of ibooks Legislature will be
different to how a lot even safer Perry
the other pages because you take point
to create the pressure it relates to the
changes for self-employed people i've
dated from South appearance of shooting
a self-employed person with the bitumen
wage for a 35-hour week I cantabria
banky simply some issues in putting the
reporter a subway person might incur
loss after loss year after year that
might happen but if there are penalties
for outstripping you know accept losses
for all the suits years in a row except
you're not trading property so their
accounts or a tax return just comes the
revenue then that will happen I I think
it's quite clear that many other
statistics is an enormous for protecting
this country self-employed where the
force or not under their earnings or
auto self-employed people are below the
minimum wage nothing is a a large
assumption to make that they were
earning the middle age minimum wage for
35-hour week other hand I support it
will cost for that part of the proposals
thank you very much anybody else wish to
speak
i vacuumed information still fit across
miquela has understandably for people of
working age the maximum percentage they
will get will receive that is that such
a supercenter well the answer them from
the so you believe an installation how
about field was divided up it possible
tonight in terms of the overall
calculation for the local council
night's game in terms of the calculation
local council tax scheme is based on the
actual initial allocation and best we
were given both in terms of government
grant that's was 19 cent of the overall
top grant and he portioned across
working age adults and also to ensure
that both of our entitles of pensions
are adequately protected the scheme
initially and in order to be balanced
indicated that the apportionment would
be at eighty percent contribution that
was in 2013-14 of the grantors in
statically reduced year-on-year so the
overall tradition now indicates that we
investing was running a deficit position
so we basically calculated the amount of
the grant that were likely to receive
and around that we are potentially going
to require in order to be balanced and
then go down to the commenter's on that
basis thank you very much I'm all happy
with everyone again so I'll happy blue
what about those idiots for that they
can either more judges back on pain
point
that's a much better now we have voted
it I'm just going a six which is a
little local council tax support except
right there are various items on it this
item I 6.1 6.2 a name is acting one and
it are you happy with add someone
dressed as elves okay before we go you
know that it was a happy need to take
anybody else want to ask questions on
this part all right so 6.21 a resolution
there 6.2 26.2 there's one two three
four five actions on that with music
which one were you kinds of outfits of
depends on two things one should take
the one at a time by number one then
different team all if we do that to my
show tonight please cute number two
it's low man number 30 so that you could
listen for my vote yet again on 8.3 from
our paperwork with Ben book on 88 we are
now up to six and we've done 6.1 and now
there's 6.2 rivet both of resolutions
are and it's two of that one I'm talking
about what we were going to agree this
too I all in agreement with it can have
a show out of those in agreement please
thank you very much those again and that
is eight my head big post number three
please those in favor of three thank you
number four no seed Raymond anybody
games you thank you so every time I put
the ghost writer that's now before they
click your name that will be fun for
them number four and down down the five
the remaining schemes except I all happy
with that okay anybody a gate so that is
item 8 and now maybe results
title by an evil people with this number
nine is report any urgent business thank
you very much then modified and fling I
believe our chairman of the mayor leaf
of the council has put a record out now
thoughts at this moment um I'm not even
plated so everybody just a good for you
oh you guys oh I won't bring it up my
report will the work of the executive
through you channel is it before that
extraordinary house waiting for 2015 16
years we here like to welcome the
members sutha meeting on the twentieth
of October the executive met twice
during which considerations to a report
on the adoption of the revised contract
these words pending the adoption of the
Revised Rules the sustainable
commissioning and procurement strategy
2015 20 was approved the outcome of the
advice services tender evaluation panel
meeting to all the advice services
contractor Citizens Advice ruptured and
rayleigh was endorsed recommendations
were mailing relations a portal to the
2015-16 revenue budget and
capitalization
reasons for variations to previously
approved budgets and setting the latest
neck rubbing your budget the outcome of
the public consultation on the LG tsg
for 2016-17 was noted and
recommendations made the customer
feedback statistics for call to 142 were
noted and the current process for
reporting endorsed and the extent report
of the chief detective program was
received other matters that my
colleagues and I are executive have been
dealing with include agreeing the
proposed amendments to the council's
allocation scheme for social housing
with revised seen being applied to the
Vatican suddenly and proving the
charging policy for the commercial use
of parking bays and higher of our parks
and the car parking charges North Campus
car locks be suspended on saturdays
during december provide for christmas as
always off your captain Baillie pressure
in respect to the work within safety I'm
sure my typically would be happy to
interview for pro- embrace any questions
I'd like to ask please thankfully
indication that are you already
previously what if they say no
oh boy
if the allocation of seats this is also
click on the subject Thank You Sharon
the political composition of the
council's changed and there's a
requirement for this to be reflected in
the allocation of seats on the council
committees and subcommittees the
appendix to reports shows seek
allocations based on a new composition
in accordance with the pro logic rules
policy comes out to endorse the appendix
the report thank you hm are you an
agreement
thank you very much Thank You chairman
secondly group leaders are being invited
to nominate gets the council's
committees based on a pro-rata
arrangement the addendum to this report
sets out the membership of committees
that it would be taking on board of
elections we see so that's the addendum
for lighting 12-channel the labor groups
indicated that he doesn't wish to 98 to
any of the four C's to which its
entitled given that the council
agreement the seats could be filled from
members of other groups in not filled
they'll be carried as vacancies the
first committee where this is a
situation is it peels committee that's
the first one capsicum do you wish to
speak on this first notion showing yes
it's actually on all four of those I
find the documents slightly pretentious
as it says on each one of those that the
later Reuters not decide to take up the
four C's giving to it but it's put down
for every single committee chair and a
fact is a two of them it looks very
strange ship with a certain age
committee they're not staying up there
for six General Authorities appendage
could be challenged right speed better
worry thank you very much yo p thank you
hmmm epogen german pleased with the
first committee to which the situation
that applies if the appeals committee of
which there's one unallocated seat any
nomination for that so there's that sign
there with one goes on it that would be
the situation show that will be the
situation from now until the end of this
Viceroy sir
showing the the second committee to
which the situation relates is the Audit
Committee where there is more than
unallocated seat thank you anybody wish
to fill a bad one the counselor please
thank you madam gym tan presently or up
until recently upset on the Audit
Committee happy to continue in that role
with counsel wishes for me to do so oh
can I have are you all agree much that
we continued service to the end of
financial year to make another one I
don't want to agreement please make a
play much thank you put 750 third
meeting to which situation of laces the
review committee there's comedy one on
allocated seat happy nomination to that
music houses above Mason oh yes yeah its
foot Minaj Economic Council missile a
sequel to the review committee and I
haven't asked us to agree whether she'd
accept the nomination so we'll be glad
in abeyance until she does otherwise I
would have by council to approve it if
she does wish to join the committee
thank you mrs. Mason just easy baby I
think thank you my chair and I am
slightly surprised mr.
but I was really serving castle
psychosis are you all happy with that
for the rest of this yeah the shower pan
thank you very much thank you daddy
thank you jerilyn finally in terms of
committees the fourth committee to which
these situation arises is the standards
committee this company one allowing a DC
Council back tell me as counsel ultram
is willing to serve that one are you
wanting to bring up the man shall pass
please thank you very much thank you
thank you chairman and then finally
there's a vacancy on the local the
homeland framework subcommittee to which
in accordance with the pro rata rules
the conservative group can nominate
absolute mr. Kaplan the gym yeah we
voted i know you do Christian nominating
to the same thing thank you very much
thank you very much for everyone and
there's nothing to say that for the rest
of this financial year the all the
committee's from have a full complement
Siri how this many members will be able
to attend them as possible to the end
this I'm at those so it can make you
very much right now
go up to number 13 is over all the TV
secretary big back James I keep you
better bring if you record the last
council meeting we took the report
forward we were looking at this point to
bring the back to pull Council for
approval in terms of deal that we were
seeking titted to get a proven say we
haven't got to that stages yet so the
current position is that we're still
continuing dialogue with civil servant
discussions taking place will be other
respective authorities within the 15
authorities and ethics and the plan
currently as it stands is for us to have
a discussion hopefully if your way them
and bring something back at the februari
their own council meeting everybody have
any questions what if executive or thank
you very much and we look forward to our
way by which i may be here tomorrow at
that time thank you very much now we go
up as a number 14 and number 14 yes I
don't fight one officer wish you support
finance office of it 11 no not me now
but there we are I know you equate
support it's my mother and I get a local
you unhappy laughable we kind of like
you work hard to start by just a spur
stating that we have an annual small
grant process and of which we allocate
grants to local the Train community
vector the overall recommended budget
for this area is 105 announcement and
450 2016-17 70,000 and this budget has
already been proposed for award to the
rocks we may leave already offered and
to which way around and business advice
bureau liga no residual 35,000 to be
awarded by this process it recommended
that as capital a greedy award and they
view delegate the authority to the
portfolio advisor route to absolute view
submissions on the small group and they
come up with the allocated compositions
about capital and making your
expenditure an accountant Thank You Joan
questions of the section 151 up stuff
this comes up every year within the
grant amount does that take into account
the free gratis and for nothing that we
give them as much as this is raised or
accommodation so we should pass many
times such a big fluid in the figure so
I guess my company said there is a
separate analysis that's actually less
at the race release that we are Kate we
can come back and give you the actual
figure all super great rich of these or
measures we will us would be
warning to future so basically three
hundred and five thousand pounds of weed
will be rewarding it's actually not
final figure it was going to take
account the accommodation angled so a is
for ant of relief from that as well so
may I ask that when we will be receiving
that figure thank you for being
efficient service contact you very
quickly on that we can never forget
something that you want to return in the
next few days very much and if I'm a
pickle wonder drug benefit little
bridges home counts it happen thank
chairman chairman to a certain extent i
believe Katsura stolen by Thunder Kozma
make that exact point in the fact that
this council doesn't only give in this
way to charity organizations also using
kinds in other ways but of course there
is a value to those things and of course
we will be including those in any figure
that comes forward because it is money
that we give to help those organization
it's only right that we publish them and
say this is this is part of our Hill for
a local community other counselors gaps
through be right in saying that and I
think that this needs to be assessed and
taking forward as well we've got the
nice bundle of papers chairman up that
high talk about tomorrow night some of
your forward to and no doubt we will try
make the correct decisions for our
community going forward thank you thank
you very much for that
I'm a 6.9 which is a vault employed to
page are you ordering that
recommendation thank you very much thank
you and now there's no 15 so go straight
at item 16 greater counselor counselor
special set time to duel with with
positions of their life
this is not 16 it is now about the focal
plane mode what is the whole point my
point is it was a mobile payments now
been changed that is why i say it with a
15 favorite thing is gone because this
is still an open meeting with anybody
present description like men this report
to the capital a so straightforward and
I having to take some questions at the
end of what I have to say but if there
is any technical questions over always
go straight to the officer on that
impression but equal if we go for option
three it will make their systems far
more flexible both for members and for
officers the system is what's known
office 365 those that we business may
well be we're finding their familiar
with the system it does work under
Microsoft Outlook and were it's our
exception it's epicenter so you can
compose the recommendation of the number
seven point luncheon Thank You Chi and
then of those questions captain Mason
here's the thing mr. Kevin here tonight
proved once the question the fundamental
question I know that we're going out so
you will find out I'd option three with
our expectation overall to find that our
ICT provision well we'll at least you
know greater apparent budget but
actually I'd like to think that it will
invest in our current budget I'm just
wondering what the intentions are with
counsel thank you can selectively
it's jaron very pious is in tension and
from the general consensus is that would
keep me up to make some confidential
things thank you anybody has any other
questions cancellation are you trying to
come back and just ask chairman ladies
message because that gives a very clear
steering direction of travel all this
see in the future if it doesn't come
back to full council thank you thank you
you know click like I just wanted to add
that with the fact that we're going out
to tender it will really be the most
cost effective solution their strength
of purpose and the ambition is that is
contained in the meeting terms war
strategy it would be difficult at this
stage to admit that it will absolutely
deliver a significant alien blood means
basically wait for the tenders to come
in evaluate and thirsty outcomes yes I'm
i only asked for the intention to to see
what the portfolio holder had put to the
immunity i completely agree there's no
way it could be committed without tender
process being completed and conducted
under the appropriate regime which of
course is extremely really very much but
there's no other questions on that
therefore on page 60 points for a no Q
Bert recommendation and the 7.1 are you
all agree p
and thank you very much occasion nervous
laugh completes an amazing time